father
sisters
if you've ever felt different i would
you were addressed to your prom dude i
don't get that of course you don't get
that if you've ever felt alone i thought
you ought to go to weight watchers camp
this summer we compromised and had a jaw
wired
[Music]
a guy like you could have a really lucky
summer in a place like this huh
[Music]
i'm starting to get that idea where
you'll fit right in you're only a few
pounds heavier than ellen i think i know
your sister cinderella
everybody's got a part
i did not sit down
you are a scary little girl and all you
need to bring is your dreams i know
you're scared it's not that my parents
are here what's about time they met
their daughter here in the dark
i stand before
you when i was eight years old i asked
my father to send me to acting class and
you know what he said you're not even
the prettiest one in your class i think
you're very pretty
[Music]
ifc films presents a comedy about drama
oh fiddler on the roof it's colorblind
casting what do you want me to do do we
look like any jews you know
who are you people
what planet did you beam down from
camp
[Music]